Starting on page three 12.
Here is the little detail.
Yeah.
This is, uh, the kid after he
has left the glance and gang.
They've been routed by the
Humas and now he is on his own.
Yeah.
He traveled about,
this is the middle of the page he
traveled about from place to place.
He did not avoid the company of other men.
He was treated with a certain deference
as one who had got on to terms with life
beyond what his years
could account for by now.
He'd come by a horse and a revolver,
the rudiments of an outfit.
He worked at different trades.
He had a bible that he'd found at the
mining camps and he carried this book with
him,
no word of which he could read
in his dark and frugal close.
Some took him for a sort of preacher,
but he was no witness to them.
Neither of things at hand, nor
things to come. He least of any man.
It's that detail of the Bible that
interests me here. He had a bible.
He'd found the mining camps,
carried this book with him,
no word of which he could read.
Why does the kid carry a Bible when he's
illiterate and why does it appear at
this moment in the narrative? These are
the questions I want to try and answer.
I want to account for this little detail
through an argument that will pick up
the points I made about allusion on
Monday and and integrate those into a
different kind of argument.
What does this Bible
signify at this moment?
The kid,
I would guess to most of you seemed like
at this point he had become somewhat
different.
Is that right?
Did you feel that by this point
when he leaves the glance and gang,
he's matured in some way?
Did you feel that? Yes. No.
Yes. Maybe if you didn't,
you swam against Mccarthy's own pros.
Remember that at a certain point,
late in the novel,
he is no longer called the kid.
He is called the man.
I'm sure most of you caught that.
What this says to us is that McCarthy
has built the structure of the narrative
along the familiar line of the buildings
from on the novel of a boy growing into
a man.
It's hard to miss this when that's the
characters only name and it changes in
the middle.
This is a fairly obvious gesture
towards that very well known narrative
structure.
There are other indicators though that
suggest a transformation of the kid or
some sort of complexity to the
kid that might be belied by the,
the narrative is conducted.
Remember that difference I pointed out
on Monday between Melville and McCarthy,
between the interiority,
you get through Ishmael as a narrator,
the complexity of him as a character
and the flatness of the kit.
You don't have an Ishmael character
whose mind you can see into.
We don't see into the minds
of these people very often.
Okay.
If the Bible signifies as it seems to do
to the people who see him and take him
to be some kind of preacher
to have some kind of wisdom,
if it's suggested development,
what kind of development is it?
The judge is the person who gives us
something to go on in this respect and if
you look on page two 99
we can see what that is.
The judge and the kid are at odds in
the desert after the route of the gang
and the kid is hiding with a loaded
gun and the judges hunting him
and he keeps calling out to the kid.
The priest has led you to this boy.
I know you would not hide.
I know too that you've not the
heart of a common assassin.
I've passed before your gun sights twice
this hour and we'll pass a third time.
Why not show yourself no assassin
called the judge and no partisan either.
There is a flawed place in
the fabric of your heart.
Do you think I could not know you
alone were mutinous you alone,
reserved in your soul.
Some corner of clemency for the heathen.
The judge sets the kid apart
from himself and from the game.
In this moment especially,
we feel that the kid has some
kind of moral superiority,
some kind of resistance to the violence
that has been dominating the novel up
until this time.
Okay.
You can see it also in a
late example of the judge.
He's,
he says that
on three Oh seven when he
meets up with the kid, uh,
much later when the kid is in prison.
This is a three oh seven,
um,
about two thirds of the way down.
Okay.
Only each was called upon to empty out
his heart into the common and one did not.
Can you tell me who that was?
It was, you whispered the kid.
You were the one and then I'm
going to skip down a little bit.
Our animosities were formed and waiting
before we two met yet even so you could
have changed at all.
The judge here again,
singles out the kid as having somehow
betrayed the gang and he suggests that
this is on the prior page. Uh,
he has lied to the authorities,
but he suggests that the kid had actually
conspired with the Humas to make it
possible for the Glanton
gang to be decimated.
That he had given them information
and allowed them to ambush the group.
He suggests that the kid was actively
working against the gang in this scene.
Is this true?
Is The kid somehow special?
Does he stand apart from the gang?
This is a question I want you to ponder.
Now.
One very distinguished reader of this
novel Harold Bloom has called the kid a
hero.
There's a preface to the modern library
edition of this novel where bloom argues
that the kid is the hero against
the heroic evil of the judge.
And remember in my discussion of Milton's
role as a source of an illusion in
this novel,
what Milton's Satan brings with him into
this novel is that sense of heroic evil
bloom sees the kid as
the heroic, good, flawed,
maybe maybe a little bit modest,
but yet still the heroic
good and bloom actually, uh,
make some mistake that I think is
quite indicative of a mistaken reading.
That's he capitalizes the kid,
he makes kid like a proper name,
capital k Kit.
You never see it that way.
In the novel
is the kid hero is
their moral development.
I want now to see whether there's any
case to be made for this and to do that,
I'm going to track the kid
through the middle of the novel.
There are about 75 pages in the exact
center of the novel where the kid does not
appear very often. This is also, um,
a structure that pertains in,
in Moby Dick. So this is again,
something that he has partly
borrowed from Melville.
When the kid does appear.
Let's see what he does. This
is during the time, by the way,
when they're just massacring anyone
who is breathing on the desert plain,
any peaceful tribe, they
come across, they will skin.
Anyone who's hair looks like
it could be an Indian scalp.
Let's look first at one 57.
This is the first place where
the kid is noted to appear. Uh,
in this,
in the section,
this is McGill emerging
from the burned encampment.
Miguel came out of the crackling fires
and stood staring blankly at the scene
about he had been skewered through with
a lance and he held the stock of it
before him. It was fashioned from a
subtle stock and the point of an old cow,
a cavalry sword bound to the Haft,
curved out from the small of his back.
The kid waited out of the
water and approached him.
And the Mexican sat down carefully
in the sand, get away from him,
said Glanton Miguel turned to
look at Glanton and as he did so,
Glanton leveled his pistol
and shot him through the head.
It looks like the kid is approaching
him as a kind of active mercy.
Here's a man skewered through with uh,
a brutal weapon and
the kid approaches him.
Glanton his response
is simply to kill him,
seeing him as more of a burden
to the gang than anything else.
But the kid approaches.
Here you do see a difference
between the kid and glancing,
at least in their
approach to McGill one 62,
a somewhat similar case.
When Davy Brown has an
Arrow through his leg,
brown has asked someone to help him push
it through so he can then extract the
arrow and everybody has refused.
As on one 61 boys said,
brown eye doctor Phi it myself,
but it can't get no straight grip.
The judge looked up at him and smiled,
will you do are Holden? No, Davey, I
won't, but I tell you what I will do.
What's that?
I'll write a policy on your life
against every mishap saved the news.
Damn you then.
So they're just kind of playing with
him and laughing with him at him as he
suffers.
Okay.
Then finally the kid rose, I'll
try her. He said, good lad,
said Brown.
And they go through the process of
pushing the Arrow through and the priest
chides him after this is all done.
When the kid returned to his own blanket,
the ex priest lean to him in his
stead, his year fool. He said,
God will not love you forever.
The kid turned to look at him.
Don't you know he'd
have took you with him?
He'd have took you boy like
a variety to the altar.
I think what he means there is that
David Brown would have killed him,
would have killed the kid if he
had had the chance somehow, uh,
in his moment of pain.
So the kid does look again,
he looks quite merciful in this passage.
We see him on one 69 at dinner
with the governor of
Chiapas and Gel Tree Os.
This is on one 69. Um, this
is a very brief mention.
Okay.
The kid in the first starched collar he'd
ever owned and the first corvette sat
mute as a tailor's dummy at that board.
I'm the ex priest has sort of indicated
with his eyes to note that the judge and
triage are conversing and
some unknown language,
a language that none of them know.
Um,
and it's as if to say
that look as if to say,
see there he has a kind of
mystical evil about him.
He speaks even in these other languages,
uh, that no one can understand.
He's an other worldly figure. The x priest
seems to be saying just with his eyes,
the kid is just like a,
a dummy.
Here he is just a blank
on one 73. This is the, um,
the passage I noted on Monday where
Toadvine and the kid are grumbling against
the judge and Glanton because of their
pension for massacring peaceful Indians
and Toadvine puts the
pistol to the judge's head.
There's a parallel moment in the desert
after the route of the gang when the kid
does not kill the judge.
The kid has his chance and he
also does not kill the judge.
So this is another appearance of the kid.
They're talking together,
and I won't read it, but you
can look at it if you like. Um,
that's on one 73,
one 78,
the kid instigates a bar fight.
This is, uh, towards
the middle of the page.
They're all assembled in a bar.
The kid address the table in his
wretched Spanish and demanded,
which among those solid inebriates
had spoken an insult, uh,
before any could own it.
The first of the funeral rockets exploded
in the street as told in the entire
company of Americans made for the door.
And this begins the chaos
that will eventuate in piles
of bodies in this Cantina
as the Americans leave.
Okay.
And then on two oh four,
this is about the time that the kid,
uh,
returns to the narrative.
This is with Shelby.
Remember,
uh, they've drawn lots
to see who will, uh,
conduct the mercy killing
yeah.
Of the wounded two or Delaware's
in one a Mexican.
The fourth was Dick Shelby and he
alone sat watching the preparations for
departure. And then the
kid, um, draws the Arrow,
but he does not kill Shelby.
He loves Shelby die in the desert.
Yeah.
These moments look like a kind of mercy,
but I'm going to argue that they are not
in fact instances of mercy that in the
end they are not accountable for by any
kind of moral calculus that they resist
that kind of evaluation.
Why?
Because every time the kid shows mercy,
he shows mercy to one of his own gang
and we know what the gang goes on to do,
right?
They simply go on killing more people.
So the allegiance that he
seems to show with suffering,
the mercy is so selective that it can't
be called such and it's a kind of trick
of McCarthy's narrative to allow us to
see the suffering of these men in this
kind of detail.
While the suffering of all the people
they kill goes by pretty quickly.
You do see infants being bashed together.
You see people run through with Lance's,
you see people's heads hacked off,
you see many scalping.
But there's never a moment when that's
really focused on that we really see it
and are asked to feel for
that suffering person.
It's spectacular violence in that literal
way that we know that word spectacle.
Okay.
There is no moral development.
Why do we think that there should be?
I've pointed out two reasons.
One is that the judge points out or
argues that or advances the rhetoric that
the kid is different from all the others.
That's one reason we think that.
The other reason is that he
transformed from kid to man.
And that old narrative of buildings,
Romano suggests the acquisition of
wisdom and we associate wisdom with moral
complexity, moral
sophistication, moral depth.
These are things we bring to the novel
out of our immersion in a cultural
tradition of such stories.
There are other reasons though,
and I'm going to go to page one 43 now.
This is the parable of the traveler.
Um,
you'll recall that this is a story that
the judge tells as a of instructive
story to the men as
they're sitting around.
And the story is that there's a
traveler passing through a wild, uh,
part of the mountains and he is a
accosted by a man who lives there.
Um,
the harness maker who lives there,
um,
invites the stranger in and
then tries to get money off him.
And then finally,
uh,
the traveler gives him
a lecture on morality.
Hmm.
In the end,
as the traveler leaves the harness maker,
uh, a cost Tim again and kills
him and buries his bones.
The wife discovers this and cares
for the bones of the traveler.
The son of the harness maker
becomes himself a killer of men.
So it's a little story that we get here.
The story seems to be about a contention
between good and evil between the
harness maker who is a
wild and chaotic force.
He lives in the woods.
He dresses up as an Indian to perpetuate
his crimes and he takes advantage of
innocent victims.
The traveler is possessed
of moral knowledge.
He can give a coherent moral speech
and he is not unwilling to exhort the
harness maker towards a better life.
Okay.
It seems to be all about moral contention.
And the point of the story from the
judge's point of view is to show that evil
is an inheritance.
So the son of a harness maker
becomes a killer of men too,
but that the lack of a father,
the traveler we find out had fathered
a child who was as yet unborn.
And so that child when born
is as the judge says, um,
euchred of his patrimony,
this is on the bottom of one 45.
All his life,
he carries before him the idol of a
perfection to which he can never attain.
The absent father takes on
this perfect a perfect model,
a quality of being, a perfect model
that the sun can never attain.
He never learns that this man was
a human being, and therefore, uh,
that he could never be the kind
of ideal he can be as a dead man.
So his point is that that child's life is,
as he says, broken before frozen
God, and he will never find his way.
What this ending of the story doesn't
tell us is that the descendants of the
traveler of the innocent victim
actually also become killers of men.
And we discovered this at
the very end of the novel
when the man makes his last kill.
And this is on three 23.
Remember the scene the
man is camped out outside,
uh,
outside the village and
this group of,
uh,
bone pickers or sort of migrants in
the desert come up to him and they're
curious about the
scapular of ears he wears.
I said on Monday that this belonged
to Toadvine. I was mistaken.
It belongs to Davie Brown. It
belonged to David Brown. I'm so,
he's wearing browns scapular of ears and
the travelers are curious about this.
And one boy in particular won't believe
him about their origin and taunts him
and sort of calls him a liar.
The group backs away that night.
That young man comes back with his gun
and he says on three 22,
I n I know you'd be hit out.
The boy called he the,
now the man pushed back,
the blanket, rolled onto his
stomach and cock the pistol.
And leveled it at the sky where the
clustered stars were burning for eternity.
He centered the foresight in the middle
groove of the frame strap and holding
the piece.
So he swung it through the dark of the
trees with both hands to the darker shape
of the visitor. I'm right here. He said,
the boys swung with the rifle and fired.
You wouldn't have lived.
Anyway, the man says, said, and they,
they come up the boy's family,
uh,
or his companions in the dawn
to get his body and they say,
top of three 23,
I know that we'd bury him on this prairie.
They come out here from Kentucky,
Mr This tyke and his brother,
his mama and daddy both dead.
His granddaddy was killed by a lunatic
and buried in the woods like a dog.
So this,
that little sentence tells us this is
a descendant of the traveler from the
judge's story.
That's who was killed by a lunatic
and buried in the woods like a dog.
The brother who's been killed by the kid.
Now the man
tried to kill the kid.
So we know that he has become a killer
of men with that same taste for mindless
violence that broods in the kid
at the very start of the novel.
And his younger brother about
12 inherits the dead boys gun.
So we see that a inheritance
yet of violence continuing.
So what appears to be a
parable, what's told to, uh,
the group of men by the judge in the form
of a parable invoking the parables of
the Bible,
which have spiritual,
moral lessons to them or can have
spiritual moral lessons to them.
Um,
that discourse is not in the end discourse
that will divide killers of men from
people who are not the killers of men.
It does not help us to divide up
the world between evil and good.
It does not track along those lines
that the judge's story about the kid,
that the kid is his nemesis,
that the kid is the
counter force to his evil.
It does not track along those lines.
And in fact,
it ran it.
The whole novel renders the
idea of a moral machinery moot.
And you can see that a little
bit too in the epigraphs.
I won't stop on those right now.
Um,
the epigraphs to the novel suggest
also the futility of a moral discourse.
I argued on Monday that there were two
threads of tradition or inheritance or
influence that McCarthy is drawing
on one historical and I know that Sam
Chamberlain's source
material from his, his, uh,
account of his life with the Glanton Gang,
and then that whole train of literary
allusions that I unearthed for you,
the historical is made moot in this
wonderful little passage from the judge if
the moral is made moot in all
these ways that I'm discussing,
the historical is dismissed quite quickly.
Three 30,
he says, men's memories is
very last line of the page.
Men's memories are uncertain and the past
that was differs little from the past
that was not think about that claim
in the context of a historical novel.
The past that was differs little
from the past that was not,
you can read the past that
was not as the fictive past.
The imagined past.
This claim is that the true past has no
significant distinction from the fictive
past, that men's memories
are no source of truths.
The past
in this little line,
Mccarthy says to us that historical
record that I was quite careful to invoke
that I was quite careful to follow in
some places from which I got lots of
detail that I used in my novel.
Forget about that.
My novel stands on an
equal plane of authority.
It gives me a platform to make equally
valid claims of truth about history and
about the world. This is a kind of, uh,
grandiloquent argument for
fiction as opposed to history
on three Oh nine.
Yeah.
We have another
interesting look back to the material
that I was talking about on Monday.
This is when the kid is
dreaming about the judge.
Um, while he's undergoing surgery
for the aero wound in his leg
in that sleep and in sleeps to follow,
the judge did visit who would come other,
uh,
great shambling Mutant,
silent and serene,
whatever his antecedents,
he was something holy other than their,
some nor was there system by which to VA
to divide him back into his origins for
he would not go.
What does that mean?
There was no system by which to divide
him back into his origins for he would
not go.
What I did on Monday was excavate some
of the origins of the judge as a figure
in Ahab, in Milton, Satan.
This tells us in the voice of the narrator
this time that you can't reduce his
character to those origins,
that to excavate the illusions
or to note the tuition,
the literary tradition out of which such
characters arise does nothing to reduce
the singularity of
McCarthy's artistic creation.
Even finding that eerily similar
description of judge Holden in Sam
Chamberlain's account,
McCarthy seems to be saying to us,
doesn't reduce him to some
understandable character
that claim for the judges.
Preeminence as a character is brought
home to us at the very end when the novel
switches to the present tense and
these remarkable claims for the judge,
and this is when they are dancing after
the kid has been killed in some horrific
manner of which were not told.
And here's the judge dancing
and you get the refrain that,
that he never sleeps. He says,
he says he'll never die, he never
sleeps. He says, he says he'll never die.
He bows to the fiddlers and sachets
backwards and throws back his head and
laughs, deepen his throat and
he's a great favor at the judge.
He walked his hat and the lunar dome of
his skull passes Paly under the lamps
and he swings about and takes possession
of one of the fiddles and d pirouettes
and makes a pass.
Two passes dancing and fiddling at once.
His feet are light and nimble. He never
sleeps. He says that he will never die.
He dances in light and in shadow and he
is a great favorite. He never sleeps.
The judge, he is dancing, dancing.
He says that he will never die.
The judge himself is a
figure for, uh, the artist.
He's a music maker.
He's a performer,
a dancer in this passage.
But the assertion is that
he will last forever.
And the only way I think to understand
that is to see him as a literary
character, very self consciously in
this moment that like Milton, Satan,
he's a character that will live in the
tradition that will never die out in the
imagination of readers.
It's a remarkably ambitious claim
to make for your own character.
But when you read it with that passage,
I just read about the impossibility
of dividing him back into his origins,
you begin to see McCarthy's
literary ambition.
And that is to add to the
tradition in a significant way.
Mccarthy's says about, um,
writing novels that it,
it's not worth doing.
You cannot write a good book
unless it's about life and death.
He dismisses,
for example,
Proust and Henry James as important
writers on this ground because they're not
writing novels about life and death.
I would argue that McCarthy needs his
novel to be about life and death because
he is looking for the sound and
the feel of literary authority
in these passages.
I'm suggesting that it's a literary
authority coming out of a miltonic
tradition,
um,
perhaps out of the tradition of American
great American novels like Moby Dick.
But it goes much deeper than that.
And this is where I get back to my
original little detail of the Bible,
the illiterate kid holding the Bible.
Two 48 we get a discussion
among the men of the Bible
in the context of a discussion of war.
This is what is said about it.
Yeah,
this is Irving,
or actually the first,
uh, Black Jackson Irving.
The good book says that he, that lives
by the sword shall perish by the sword,
said the black. The judge smiled
his face shining with Greece.
What right man would have
it any other way. He said,
the good book does indeed count.
Warren evils said Irving. Yet.
There's many a bloody
tale of war inside it.
I would argue that this is a
description of McCarthy's own book,
except there's one thing that's different.
The good book does indeed count.
Warren Evil Mccarthy's novel does not
fail in making us see more as evil because
we're confronted over and over again with
these scenes of violence over and over
again with it's gratuitous nature.
We feel the waist.
When that last young boy
is killed by the man,
we feel the waist of his life.
We see,
feel the tragedy in discovering that the
sons of the harness maker and the sons
of the traveler both come to the
same end and become killers of men.
We see that evil
and like the Bible.
There is many a bloody a tale within it.
It Does Not Count Warren Evil because
it has not allowed a moral machinery to
have a place in this universe
or in the logic of the novel.
Why did holds out instead
is the feeling of morality,
the feeling that you could have a rhetoric
that would divide the kid from the
judge in a meaningful way that would
divide killers of men from not killers of
men
that would divide the good from the evil,
that would divide the
peaceful from the war.
Like even that would divide
history from fiction.
If there's something moral
about the truth of history,
why does McCarthy used the pattern and
the sound of Biblical language throughout
the novel?
I think this is why Robert Alter,
who if you've, if studied, um,
the Bible in any college course,
you've probably a at least
come to know his work.
He is a great translator
of the Old Testament. Um,
and he came out recently with a version,
I think it was in 2004 called, um,
which he titles the five books of Moses.
It's the pentitude and it's
retranslated in a very startling style.
It's trying to,
um,
honor the syntax of the Hebrew,
which is paratactic,
which means that it's strung together
with ANZ rather than subordinated.
The way that latinate
languages are subordinated.
So the King James Bible has in the
English tradition been the prestigious
literary translation of the Bible
Alter in 2004 tries to make the modern
equivalent of the King James Bible. And
in the introduction to that translation,
he says that what he's trying to do is
to take the innovations of writers like
Stein, Faulkner and the only
one from the late 20th century.
He mentions McCarthy to make a Bible
that is true to the Hebrew syntex.
This citation from alter is foremost
scholar on the Bible and Biblical
translation suggest just how successful
McCarthy has been in persuading the ear
that he is writing something like
scripture. He has persuaded alters ear
that
this book is the
equivalent of Hebrew pros.
Okay.
He's so successful in doing that that
he can make these gigantic claims and I
would point you back to
the beginning of the novel.
Yeah.
This citation of his father,
the only line we get a really about,
um, the kid's father, his
father has been a school master.
He lies and drink.
He quotes from poets
whose names are now lost.
Its as if McCarthy is telling us I'm
erasing all that past that I'm invoking
from the Bible on up from the
Bible to the Iliad to Milton,
to Wordsworth to Melville.
I'm invoking it all.
But forget all those names.
Remember just one
the judge
or better yet McCarthy.
That's the one that you can remember.
So McCarthy gives us the feel of scripture
and yet he erases all that could
be the content of scripture.
That's why I'm interested in the Bible,
in the hand of an illiterate kid.
What is the Bible in the
hand of an illiterate kid?
But the symbol of that kind of narrative,
the symbol that there can be
an authoritative narrative
about the nature of the
world, about all of history, about
its meaning, about its structure,
a book that can compel its readers that
can speak to life and death in the most
ultimate way.
Okay.
But because it's in the hand of an
illiterate person, it cannot be read.
So what McCarthy is saying to us in
that tiny detail is that the Bible is
important as an artifact,
as a literary artifact.
Proof that such narratives can exist.
And McCarthy sets out to produce one.
Yeah.
And in keeping with the
illiterate newness of the kid,
one that has no moral content at all has
only made claims about the material of
the universe and not be spiritual
quality of the universe.
And that persuades entirely by the sound
of rhetoric and the structures that are
familiar to us from the
narratives of our tradition.
That's the ambition of the novel.
Um,
I'm actually right on time,
so I will stop there.